I'm Wayne Pacelle, and I've
been privileged to serve
as president and CEO of the
Humane Society of the United
States, headquartered
in Washington, DC,
for the last 11 years.
And I've been with
the organization
for the last 21 years.
I used to be the chief political
and communications person.
And my colleague,
Josh Balk is here.
He helps run our Farm Animal
Protection Department.
And he also has created
a company in this area,
a food company
called Hampton Creek,
which is the fastest growing
food company ever in terms
of its sales and certainly its
impact on sector of industry.
That company is producing
a plant-based alternative
to eggs.
And the product is already in
tens of thousands of stores.
It's being picked up by
the biggest food companies.
And Josh just did that on
his side time with HSUS.
So what I wanted to
do today is give you
a little bit of a picture of
what the animal protection
cause is about, but
also to talk to you
about some of the themes
of the upcoming book
that I'm working on.
It'll be out in March,
called "The Humane Economy",
where essentially I'm
arguing that we're
in a revolutionary moment in
terms of our human relationship
with animals.
And that part of
the driving activity
is entrepreneurialism
and innovation
making many forms of traditional
animal exploitation obsolete.
And that we're going to have new
options and opportunities that
are going to require
no sacrifice for us,
but that are going to up-end
many conventional uses
of animals.
So the opening slide
here, of course,
is kind of the
archetypal example
of what I think of as
the humane economy, which
is whale watching.
The United States used to
be the greatest whaling
nation in the world--
greatest not in terms of best,
but greatest in
terms of largest.
And ships would leave the ports
on mainly the East Coast--
Nantucket and New Bedford,
and ply the world's oceans,
and kill fin whales and right
whales and humpback whales,
and exploit them for their
oil and their blubber.
But of course, then there
was a huge innovation
in terms of petroleum, which
made whale oil obsolete.
Our values began to progress.
We used to think of whales
as just these things.
We began to recognize they're
the largest creatures who've
ever lived on the
planet, and maybe we
should start to protect them.
So we, as a nation, went
from this incredible industry
where mansions and big buildings
were built around the whaling
economy.
And now the whaling ships
are just in museums.
If you go to Nantucket, you
can go to the Whaling Museum.
But you won't see any
US whalers in operation.
And I think that is
an indicator of what's
going to happen in so many
other sectors of the animal use
economy.
So just a quick word
about the Humane Society
of the United States.
We're one of 25,000 animal
protection organizations
in the United States.
We're the largest of them.
But there are local humane
societies that are SPCA's.
There are 13,000 or 14,000
animal rescue groups,
whether they're
doing feral cats,
or they're doing
dog rescue by breed.
There may be a St Bernard
rescue or Chihuahua rescue.
There are hundreds of wildlife
rehabilitation facilities
all around the United States.
Then there are groups of
focus on farm animals.
There are groups
just devoted to that,
or animals that
are entertainment.
Or there are groups to protect
black bears, or mountain lions.
There's this
incredible pluralism
that exists when it
comes to our relationship
with animals that's reflected in
so many different organizations
which, collectively, are really
in the marrow of our culture
now.
There is just no question that
animal protection sensibilities
are part of our American
ethos, and increasingly,
the global ethos, in terms
of the human relationship
to animals and Nature.
So we do protect
all animals, which
was the reason for this slide--
that we're not just about dogs.
We're not just about cats.
We're not just about horses.
We're about all creatures.
They all matter in this world.
And we want to be
their advocates.
We've been around for a
little more than 60 years.
And this is the
chair of the board
starting the organization.
And the humane movement
really got its start
in the period right
after the Civil War.
So after the United States dealt
with his great moral problem
of slavery, people
began to think
about our responsibilities
to animals.
And most social movements
are born out of crisis.
There's a terrible
circumstance that
warrants people of conscience
to rise up and do something.
And the environmental movement
really began in the 1860s,
with this
hyperexploitation of Nature
as we were conducting
our westward expansion
in the United States.
And we were liquidating
the buffalo, and the elk,
and the wolves, and all
of the other creatures.
And there were some
people who said, no, we've
got to place limits on this.
And George Perkins Marsh
wrote a book called
"Man and Nature" in 1862.
And he saw the beginning
of a conservation ethic
which, a couple of
decades later, was really
typified by Theodore Roosevelt.
But around the same time,
we also saw the humane
movement organizing.
And the biggest
form of abuse was
the abuse of horses in cities.
We were this agrarian economy.
But we began to see new
immigrant communities.
And we began to
aggregate ourselves
in these bustling
cities of Philadelphia,
New York, and other cities.
And people were using
horses for transportation.
And people were
overworking horses.
They were beating horses.
They were overloading horses.
And Henry Bergh, for
one, in New York--
a New York socialite-- said
we have got to stop it.
And he formed the ASPCA,
the American Society
for the Prevention of
Cruelty to Animals.
And then in the
late 1860s, 1870s,
there were similar
groups created
in different communities all
around the United States.
So the Humane Society
of the United States
came many years later.
It actually spun off from
another organization.
And the chairman of the board
said, driving us to organize
was the feeling that the
American Humane Movement
needed a national society
that would stand absolutely
on humane moral principles--
an organization that
would unequivocally,
vigorously, adamantly oppose
any and every kind of cruelty,
no matter by whom committed,
and without concern for who
might be offended or alienated.
The notion was that there
were lots of local groups.
They were doing
critically important work
in their communities,
most of it rescue.
But who was going to address
the root causes of cruelty?
Rescuing, while vital because
animals are in crisis,
inevitably addresses the
symptoms of a problem.
What is the cause or the
impetus for the exploitation
in the first place?
If you're just rescuing the
victims after they're injured,
in some ways you're late.
And you're also
not getting at why
the circumstance
exists that's producing
this terrible
condition for animals.
So one of the big precepts
that we operate with is,
you cannot rescue your way
out of the crisis for animals.
Think about our world, and
how many animals there are.
We've got 171 million dogs
and cats in our homes.
There are anywhere from 10
to 100 million feral cats
roaming outside in
the United States.
In the US, we raise 9
billion animals a year
for food, 70 billion worldwide.
The 7 billion people on the
planet-- for every one of them,
there are 10 farm animals.
There are billions
of wild animals,
countless, countless
billions of wild animals,
of hundreds of species.
I think there are
8,000 species of birds.
There are thousands
of mammal species.
And then when you go to other
categories or classifications
of animals, there are
thousands more of them.
Animals are used
in entertainment.
They're used in science.
They're used in
wildlife management.
They're used in food
and agriculture.
They're used in so
many different domains.
If we were really good,
and spent our resources
very effectively, maybe we could
rescue 500,000, or 600,000,
or 700,000 animals in a year.
But by working to change the
way institutions operate,
and getting animals
out of circumstances
where alternatives now exist,
or making things more humane,
we can affect the lives
of billions of animals.
So at the Humane Society
of the United States,
more than any
other organization,
take a highly strategic
approach to how
we confront this human
relationship with animals.
And at base level,
it's not so much
that we talk about
animal rights.
It's a common term that
people use-- animal rights.
A lot of people debate, do
animals have natural rights?
Do we confer them upon animals?
We kind of sidestep
that entire question,
because really, it's about us.
It's not so much
about the animals.
I mean, yes, we
have to understand
that animals are conscious.
They're thinking.
They have feelings.
They have families.
They value their lives as
much as we value our lives.
But it's we who are doing
these things to these animals.
It's more about us
than it is about them.
So rather than talk
about animal rights,
we talk about human
responsibility.
How do we handle
the immense power
that we have over
other creatures?
We hear this term
"asymmetry" in defense
and international relations--
that the United States
has an asymmetrical
relationship to other countries
because we have all this power.
Well, we have an asymmetrical
relationship with animals.
We hold all the cards.
They are at our mercy.
We can do anything we want to
them, because we are so much
more powerful than they are.
Think back to that
period when we
were liquidating these
wildlife species in the 18060s.
150 years ago, we
had that power.
There were 40 to
60 million buffalo
that were roaming the
mid-section of the North
American continent.
We dropped their numbers
to 500 in the span
of about three decades.
We wiped out billions
of Passenger Pigeons
in the span of 40 years.
The last one died in
captivity in 1914.
So even then, a century
ago, we had the power
to liquidate entire species,
wipe them from the planet.
Imagine now what we can
do with our technology.
So it's really about who we are.
So these are the four
areas in which we work.
We do rescue and direct
care, because, as I said,
animals are in crisis.
We've got a whole
range of programs
where we come to
the aid of animals.
Second is we do public
awareness and education,
because so many people
care about animals.
But they don't know what
problems afflict them.
We need to educate people
about what's going on,
and also to provide solutions
so people of conscience can act.
We also try to shape
the laws, because laws
are designed in a civil
society to maintain order,
but they're also designed
to reflect our values.
They're the rules of the
road for civil society.
And when it comes to
animals, we need standards.
A tiny percentage of people in
a society of 320 million people
can create a lot of havoc.
Look at Michael Vick
in dog fighting,
or other people involved
in dog fighting.
You could have
just 10,000 people
involved in an enterprise
like dog fighting,
and victimize hundreds
of thousands of dogs.
So we must have rules to
set a baseline standard
that folks can't violate.
And it's not just a matter
of our personal preference.
There are lives at stake.
You're shielding
vulnerable creatures
from cruelty and abuse, which
is a core value in our society.
And finally, and I
think this is really
the theme of what I wanted
to talk about today,
is our corporate reform work.
Obviously, Google and
the many companies
that are associated
with Google have
been part of this incredible
information and technology
revolution in the last 20
years, the last quarter century.
I mean, it's reshaped
our entire economy.
That's what we need for animals.
That's what we're
trying to drive.
And you're going to see today
how so many companies are
really at the leading
edge of a revolution
in our human relationship
to animals and Nature.
But those are the
four legs of the table
on which all of the
activities of the Humane
Society of the United States
and its affiliates stand.
And again, one of
the great things
about our work at
the Humane Society
is, we don't have to invent
a social concern for animals.
The book that you may have
passed by walking in here,
I wrote a book called
"The Bond," where
I argue that we humans have
an instinctive relationship
to other creatures.
Kids-- you see it.
I mean you were all kids at
one point, I imagine, right?
Kids have this connection
to other creatures.
I mean, it's manifest
by kids being
fascinated by animals on TV.
They have animals as toys.
90% of the images in
kids' books are animals.
There are so many
different expressions
of this, which I'll
talk about in a moment.
But people love animals.
If we start with that,
we have a head start
in the fight to help animals.
And we're now spending more
than $60 billion a year
on our dogs and cats,
171 million dogs
and cats in our home.
So you can get all
sorts of things.
There are spa treatments
for animals now.
There's organic food.
And there's so many
different expressions
of this love and appreciation.
And most people consider
them part of the family.
We also love to see wildlife.
We have a whole network of
National Parks, National
Forests, Bureau of
Land Management lands.
We've got state parks.
We've got city parks.
Even in the kind of
greatest expression
of human civilization and
physical and architectural
development like New York City--
right in the middle of the city
is a park.
The planners
designed it that way
because we're
connected to Nature.
Even when we have
tall skyscrapers,
we still want to
be around nature.
We're the first
country in the world
to create a National
Park-- 1872, Yellowstone--
and now it's been emulated
throughout the world.
There's a network of national
parks all throughout the world,
because it's a
tonic to our soul.
We need to be in Nature.
It's part of who we are.
Because for 99%
of human history,
we were living in
pre-agricultural settings.
We were tribal societies.
The tribal societies had
an intimate knowledge
of the animals in the forest.
They knew when they bred.
They knew what they were like.
They knew the floral
kingdom as well.
Nature is built into
every one of us.
And I argue in my
book that it really
is a sort of biophilia--
a love of nature
that's built into
each one of us.
And it's manifest
with all the wildlife
watching that goes on as well.
But it's broader than that.
We have 2/3 of
American households,
as I mentioned, have a pet.
91% of people
consider their pets
to be members of the family.
95% of us agree
it's important to me
that farm animals
are well cared for,
because the way that we
interact with animals more
than any other is on our plates.
The average American
eats 31 animals a year.
So think of 320 million
people times 30 or 31.
That's 9 billion animals.
That's how you get that total.
Most of them are chickens,
because they're small.
If we ate just beef, it
would be a far smaller number
of animals, because
they're larger.
They go farther.
But you eat a
piece of a chicken,
it's like a third
of the chicken.
And that accounts for
this enormous number
of animals used for food
production in our society.
But even with that, people
want to see those animals more
humanely treated than they are.
As I mentioned, lots of
people watch wildlife.
This is an interesting chart.
In 1985, just a few years before
I got to the Humane Society,
this was what the
legal situation
looked like with three
types of animal cruelty.
States that had felony level
penalties for dog fighting,
and anti-dog fighting
laws in general, states
had anti-cock fighting laws
with felony level penalties.
Then states that
had a general animal
cruelty statute, where
malicious cruelty
was treated as a felony.
You can see that just a
small number of states
had these statutes in 1985.
It was really a
patchwork with about 10,
12 states with felony level
penalties for dog fighting,
smaller number
with cock fighting,
and a very small number
with felony cruelty.
We said at the Humane
Society, this can't stand.
I mean, if we're going
to advocate for animals,
there must be a baseline
standard with cruelty.
So we have methodically
gone state by state,
and now this is what
the map looks like.
We have filled out the map.
This notion that animal cruelty
is wrong is now universal.
It's now treated as a
serious crime to be malicious
and to be cruel
toward an animal.
You can go to jail.
You can be fined.
And really, one of
the things that we're
doing at the Humane
Society of the US
is saying, OK, if
animal cruelty is wrong,
if this is a moral problem,
how do we logically
apply anti-cruelty principles
in a world where animals are
embedded in so many
different aspects of our life
and in the economy?
They're used for food.
They're used in science.
Wildlife are all around us.
They're used in the pet trade.
They're used in entertainment.
If this notion is
meaningful, and it's sticky,
we've got to more logically
apply the principle.
So that's really what
we're engaging in
at the organization.
And this really leads to
this notion of a disconnect.
We say that we love animals.
We have all that pet keeping
and wildlife watching.
We have anti-cruelty laws.
Most people-- just about
every decent person's
not going to say it's OK
to be cruel to an animal.
Yet we live in a world where
there's so much exploitation.
I mean, we have this
tangled, contradictory, even
schizophrenic
relationship with animals.
And that's the cultural
and economic climate
in which we're operating
right now, as we do
our work at the Humane Society.
Think of pets.
We love our pets.
Yet we have 10,000 puppy
mills in the United States,
churning out dogs
for the pet trade,
keeping the mother dogs
in cages, in confinement,
exposing them to extremes
of heat and cold,
denying them vet care, not
providing proper socialization.
At a time when we're struggling
with the local humane studies,
SPCA's and county and municipal
animal care control facilities
to adopt out animals
and stop euthanasia,
we're still euthanizing
3 million healthy dogs
and cats every year in the US.
This is an image
of a puppy mill.
Many of these puppy
mill operators
used to be involved
in agriculture.
They were pig farmers who
got out of the business
and started raising dogs.
And they adopt many of the same
strategies in raising them.
They're kind of a
production unit.
But there's a change happening.
And PetSmart and Petco,
as two big pet supply
chains in the mid 1990s
said, we're going to stop.
We're not going to continue
selling dogs from puppy mills
at our pet stores.
We're now going to partner with
rescue groups and shelters,
and make dogs and cats
available at our facilities.
And since that time, more
than 10 million dogs and cats
have been adopted out through
PetSmart and Petco outlets.
This is part of this
new humane economy.
In fact, in 2014 the
largest private equity deal
in the world was
PetSmart being purchased
for more than $7 billion by
a London-based private equity
firm.
So the biggest global
private equity deal
was a pet store company-- quite
an amazing change in the world.
There are other problems
for dogs in the world.
And 20 million slaughtered in
Asia for human consumption.
We've been working to stop this.
We're working with
Chinese advocates
to stop this on the
ground in that country.
The images are horrifying.
If you go to our website, we've
got a whole video channel.
Our teams have helped to
shut down several farms.
We've actually brought a
number of these dogs back.
In fact, we brought some of
them to San Francisco recently.
Several of the farms
were shut down,
and we adopted a bunch them
out through the San Francisco
SPCA and a number of
other local societies.
The use of animals in
entertainment-- many of you,
I'm sure, have
heard, some of you
have watched the
documentary, "Blackfish--"
one documentary exposing Sea
World's mistreatment of orcas,
the history of capturing them
from their pods in the wild,
bringing them into captivity,
high mortality rates,
very shortened lifespans,
and constant frustrations
for animals that roam 10s
and 10s of miles every day
in the ocean.
They live in family groups where
they stay with their family
members for a lifetime.
There's one orca
off of Puget Sound
who is estimated to have
turned 106 recently.
I mean, these animals
are incredible.
They're the biggest
predators in the world.
And they're in a little
tank at Sea World,
like a big swimming pool.
It'd be like you and me living
in a closet for the rest
of our lives-- away from
their family members,
eternally frustrated, biting
at the side of the pool,
scraping their face,
breaking their teeth.
And occasionally,
some of the trainers
get killed, because
they're so frustrated.
They lash out.
They get angry and
upset, just like we
would if we were in a
situation of deprivation,
if we were in
solitary confinement.
What's amazing is so many
kids and other people
have responded, Sea World
stock, after one documentary
was aired, has gone down.
It was up well above 40.
Now it's less than 20.
And CNN kept replaying
this documentary.
And of course, now people have
access to things like YouTube.
And they can see this stuff.
We're really closing the
gap between what people want
and what happens, because we're
giving people information.
And Google, and
YouTube, and others
are part of that
information revolution
that's changing the way people
are behaving, because they have
information they can act upon.
These channels of
information delivery
are crucial to building
a humane economy,
because the basis of it is
an informed consumer who's
making choices in
the marketplace
to reflect these sensibilities.
And earlier this year, something
happened that I didn't think
was going to happen for
another 10 or 20 years.
Ringling Brothers decided
to give up its elephants
in its circus acts.
I mean, this is a company that
infiltrated animal welfare
groups, that spent
$10s of millions
to defend its use of elephants.
And they realized
that customers didn't
want these elephants to be on
chains 22 or 23 hours a day,
shuttled in the box cars to
120 or 130 cities a year.
The only time they
get off the chain
is when they walk from their
miserable holding place
to the arena where they're going
to do a performance, where they
stand on their head-- where
a 180 pound person is giving
a command to a
five-ton elephant.
The only reason they do
that is because they're
in fear, because they've been
brutalized with a bull hook
or other apparatuses or
devices that cause them fear.
In fact, the California
legislature just yesterday
passed a bill to ban
the use of bull hooks
statewide in a key committee.
It's already passed one chamber.
We hope it's soon to
go to the governor
to stop the use of
these bull hooks, which
are like a baseball bat with
a sharp metal hook on the end.
And that's how they
dominate the elephants,
and get them to
do what they want.
Other circuses, like
International Circus,
after Ringling made its
announcement in March,
also said it's giving
up its elephants.
So here's a cartoon where
the elephant is just telling
the Sea World orca, "Hold on.
Relief is coming."
There's no species
that's had a bigger
impact on the American
culture than the horse.
I mean, horses changed our
notions of time and space.
They allowed for
westward expansion
in the US, allowed for transport
before the internal combustion
engine.
We owe horses a great
debt of gratitude.
Yet we're shipping 150,000
horses a year from the US
to slaughter plants
in Mexico and Canada,
which slaughter the horses, then
ship them to Europe and Asia
for human consumption-- I
mean, just a very poor way
to pay back horses
for all that they've
done for us in our culture.
We're working to stop that.
And we've gotten the Europeans
to suspend horse meat imports
from Mexico.
And we think that they may
be doing it soon in Canada.
Because these horses are
coming up the racetrack.
They're coming out of
working facilities.
They're dosed with all sorts
of medicines that are forbidden
for human consumption.
It's amazing-- the Europeans
forbid US-produced chicken,
pork, and beef from being
imported into the EU,
because our American industrial
farmers dose these animals
with drugs that the Europeans
consider to be unsafe.
Yet we've got 129 different
drugs that are routinely
used on horses that are not
fit for human consumption
here in the US.
The Europeans were
finally-- we finally
convinced them to better align
their food safety policies
for horses along with the
other species that are
consumed for human consumption.
And there's also a
tremendous love affair
that we have with wildlife,
especially elephants.
And we love elephants,
yet right now, there's
a terrible crisis going on, with
35,000 elephants being killed
a year, principally
for their ivory,
principally by militias
and terrorist groups that
are financing their terrorism
by slaughtering elephants
and selling the ivory.
If you don't have a bank to rob,
if you're out in a rural area,
you can go slaughter elephants,
and translate ivory into cash,
and finance efforts
to shoot up people
at malls like the Westgate Mall
in Nairobi, or go to a school,
as they did in Kenya, and
slaughter 70 or 80 students.
The people doing the
poaching are terrorists.
It's not just a poor African
who is trying to get by
and killing an elephant.
There is an incredible link
that's well documented.
And we're fighting
this on the ground.
But we're also fighting
it in the US and China,
which are the two largest
markets for ivory.
The reason that people
are killing elephants
is because consumers are
placing value on the ivory.
We've got to stop the
trade in the ivory
if we're going to stop
the poaching in Africa.
And in terms of
the humane economy,
African elephants
are ecologically
the keystone species
throughout so much of Africa.
You protect the elephants, you
protect all the other animals.
And the elephants have
this incredible impact
on the vegetative community.
They can knock down trees.
They can create savanna.
But they're also economically
the keystone species
for Africa.
Millions of people
throughout the world
go to African countries to see
elephants, and also rhinos,
and other great,
remarkable species--
prehistoric looking creatures.
It's billions of dollars.
So there's been all sorts
of economic analysis--
that a living elephant
is 76 times more
valuable than a dead elephant.
The humane economy
is about realizing
what the true economic
potential of animals is.
And they're much more
valuable alive than dead,
as we discovered with whales.
We now have a
multi-billion dollar whale
watching industry that,
in comparative terms,
would have dwarfed
what whaling was when
it involved killing of whales.
So that's the humane
economy in progress.
Now even China has
announced that it's
going to end the ivory trade.
This is a very,
very hopeful sign.
This announcement came
just a few weeks ago.
And there are other forms
of exploitation of wildlife.
The largest marine mammal
slaughter in the world
is the killing of
harp and hooded
seals on the Atlantic seaboard
of Canada-- Prince Edward
Island, Newfoundland, Labrador.
And 400,000 seals were
killed for their pelts--
for fur-- not for local use.
These are not
tribal communities.
These are folks who are
going out, killing the seals
on the ice floes,
and then shipping
the pelts all over the world.
So we took this on in 2005.
And the white is
the quota that was
set by the national wildlife
and marine authorities.
They could kill 335,000, or they
could kill 330,000, 400,000.
The blue is the actual kill,
because what we did is,
we started closing markets
throughout the world.
We got the European Union to
ban imports of seal skins.
We got Mexico to ban
imports of seal skins.
We've gotten China
to restrict it.
So now, they have no reason
to go kill the animals,
because the pelts are valueless.
And this year was the smallest
seal kill in a generation,
precisely because of our
work in the global economy--
that millions of people
are now aware of this,
and they're saying they're
not going to buy it.
And politicians are
saying, we don't want it.
We don't want this cruelty to
be associated with our commerce.
And the use of animals
in laboratories
is a very significant issue.
The United States has been
the last nation in the world
to allow chimpanzees to be
used in invasive experiments.
We did an undercover
investigation
that the largest
chimp facility, which
is in Louisiana,
several years ago.
And since that time,
we've been campaigning
to end the use of
chimps in experiments.
And we're basically
to that point
now, where the head of NIH--
which two years ago made
an announcement with us
that NIH is getting out
of the business of using
chimps in experiments--
that they're going
to ship out 400
of their government-owned
chimps to sanctuaries over time,
and end the invasive
experimentation on animals.
So Doctor Heilig said,
"Pretty much everybody
has gotten out, or is getting
out, of research with chimps."
Because now we have
sophisticated ways
to test medicines.
We've got sophisticated
ways to test for toxicity
without using a whole animal.
We have organ on a chip, and
we have computational tests,
and we have all sorts
of innovative ways
that are cheaper, don't
involve intense animal care,
and we can find out
more reliable things
by doing experiments
in these ways,
or research in these ways.
And then the Fish and Wildlife
Service, Jane Goodall and I
announced just at
the end of June
that all chimpanzees, whether
they're captive or wild,
they're going to be
classed as endangered.
Which means that their use
in film and commercials,
in the pet trade, as well
as in biomedical research,
is all going to be subject to
very high levels of scrutiny
now-- so a big revolution in
our relationship with chimps.
And this issue of
testing on animals--
for many, many
decades, we've been
testing mascaras, and
lipsticks, and detergents,
and other household products and
cosmetics on animals in labs.
We force-feed them,
where there's a test
called the lethal dose 50,
where you provide so much
of a substance that
half of the control
group-- if it's 50
rabbits, 25 of them
die from poisoning-- half of
them, 50% is the lethal dose.
Or we do the Draize
eye irri irritancy
test where we dip
chemicals in their eyes.
And cause-- I mean, imagine we
get a little soap in our eye
and we try to rinse
it out and scrub it.
These animals have no way that
they can get to their eye.
They're in some
sort of stockade.
And we dump this concentrated
product in their eye
specifically to cause injury
to them, as a way of testing.
Well, now we're down to just
about 100,000 in animals
used in our country.
We've got legislation
in Congress
called the Humane Cosmetics Act,
to end this once and for all.
And we just got Europe to
ban it in all 28 countries.
And we, last year,
got India to ban it.
So 1.7 billion people in the
global market now cannot even
buy cosmetics tested on animals.
This is going to change the
way things are happening.
India banned it, as
I said, last year.
And now all of these companies
as part of the growing humane
economy are saying
no to animal testing.
And they're marketing
their products by saying,
we're not testing on animals.
And this one here, Coty, you
may have heard in the news--
they just bought a
whole bunch of divisions
of Procter & Gamble
the other day
for several billion dollars.
They're already a
non-animal testing company
and they bought P&G.
So this is the progress
of the humane economy.
And fur-- I mean,
there's just no excuse
to kill animals for their fur.
We can make synthetic coats
and natural fiber coats
are just as warm and just as
stylish without causing animals
to suffer in leg-hold
traps or in fur factories.
There's just no point.
And last week, we announced
with Hugo Boss, one
of the major fashion
companies, a luxury brand,
that it is completely
eliminating fur
from its collections.
We're negotiating with
several other luxury brands
now to get past
this era of killing
animals for their pelts.
There's just no need.
Many of these faux fur garments
are so authentic-looking that
you cannot tell the difference.
If you can't tell
the difference,
then why would you kill
20, or 30, or 40 animals
to stitch together their fur?
Now all of these companies
have made commitments
on the fur issue.
So you can see, in all different
sectors of the economy,
corporations are
now taking action.
And the biggest
area, as I mentioned,
is the rearing of
animals for food.
We say that we love animals, yet
we're eating 9 billion of them
a year.
And the conditions in which
the vast majority of them
are raised are so bad
that it would, and should,
turn the stomach of
anyone with a conscience
for other creatures.
I mean, this is an image of
an industrial pig facility
with sows in gestation crates.
This is the standard industry
practice for the last 45 years,
to keep sows in place.
They have them in a two
foot by seven foot cage,
where they can take one step
forward, and one step back.
That's it.
And they're there for
four months, which
is their gestation period.
They're moved to another
crate for just a short time.
They're almost
immediately re-impregnated
and put back in this crate.
So for seven, eight, nine,
10 successive pregnancies,
they're immobilized.
These are sociable
herd animals that
have a great nose that they use
to root around in the ground.
And they want to move around.
And they want to play
like other animals.
And they're living on a
concrete slatted floor.
And there's space in between
so the manure and the urine
can fall into a
lagoon beneath them.
And all that ammonia then
comes up as water evaporates.
And they can't move.
So I don't care if you're
a vegan, or vegetarian,
or an inveterate carnivore.
There's a problem with this.
Wherever you are terms of
your own dietary preferences,
this must stop.
And we're working to stop it.
This is, unfortunately, the
attitude of the major trade
association with the industry.
Guy said, in response
to our campaign
to end the use of
the crates, he said,
"So our animals can't
even turn around
for two and a half years.
I don't know who asked the sow
if she wanted to turn around."
I mean, you can look
at these comments,
and you can look
back at our history,
and see how men denied women
the right to vote-- said,
oh, well, they shouldn't
be able to vote.
They shouldn't be
making policy decisions.
The same country that
had chattel slavery,
and said a whole race
or group of people
should be conscripted
into forced labor--
we've done some really
unpleasant things
in our society.
But we've always, as a society,
overcome these problems
through reason, and
science, and logic,
and reliance on our founding
principles in the Declaration
of Independence and
the Constitution,
of justice and equality.
You cannot have terrible
injustice to people,
and look back upon our
founding documents,
and say that's consistent.
Well, I don't think
we can say that we're
an anti-cruelty society and
tolerate this sort of behavior.
We've got to conform our
behavior with our values
and our principles.
There must be a realignment.
And it should be happening
in agriculture as well.
And it is.
These are all companies
that my colleague Josh
Balk has negotiated
with, and his colleagues
in our Farm Animal Department--
negotiated agreements
with all these companies to
phase out the purchase of pork
from operations like
the one you saw,
that confined the
sows in those crates.
This has just happened in
the last three or four years,
when McDonald's-- we announced
in a joint release with
McDonald's in February
or January 2012,
that they were going to phase
out the purchase of pork from
operations in all
these companies--
with the exception of a
couple who preceded it,
like Whole Foods.
This is a major revolution.
And we've got to
continue to propel it.
And the other area
is the treatment
of the hens used for eggs.
These hens are kept
in battery cages.
They're small, wire cages
where six or eight birds
are kept in a cage for their
entire life-- 12 or 18 months.
And the amount of
space that the bird has
is 67 square inches of
space-- under the industry
voluntary standard.
Now, there are a bunch of
egg production companies
that keep birds in 48
or 54-inch allotments.
But again, their standard,
their high standard
is 67 square inches.
Well, this is an eight and
a half by 11 sheet of paper.
Eight and a half
times 11 is what?
93.
So 67 square inches is 2/3 the
size of this sheet of paper.
This is the living space that
the hen has for the 18 months
that she's alive.
And she's in there with
six or seven other birds.
So imagine if seven or eight
of us were in a small elevator,
and we never got out.
I mean, if we were in
there for 10 or 15 minutes,
if that elevator gets stuck
and we're jammed in there,
you better believe most of
us are going to go crazy.
Imagine if you're there
for a day, or for a month,
or for a year.
This is what we're doing
to animals raised for food.
I mean, if you came
from another planet
and saw what we're doing to
these animals, you'd say,
my god, this is incredible.
We keep them as pets.
And we treat them
as family members.
Yet we're doing this to
them for food production?
So California was the state
that really started this.
Some of you who've been
in this state for awhile
may remember this.
We did a ballot measure in
2008 called Proposition 2.
And this is the vote
result for Prop.
2.
There are 58 counties
in California.
The green-shaded
counties favored Prop 2,
and the red-shaded
counties opposed it.
But overall, it got
63.5% of the vote
to stop extreme
confinement of laying hens,
breeding sows and veal calves.
It got more votes than
any other initiative
in American history--
for farm animals.
So the public is waking up.
And I'm sure if you
voted in that election--
this was Obama's
first election--
the presidential election was on
the same ballot-- you probably
voted yes on this ballot
measure, because it made sense.
Animals built to move.
Should be allowed to move.
Even animals raised for food
deserve humane treatment.
And Prop.
2 took effect January 1st.
It had a six-year phase-in,
because it was so moderate,
it allowed the farmer
six years to transition
to more humane systems.
It finally took
effect this year.
And now, we've worked with all
of these companies-- really,
Josh has in the
last six months--
most of them have
made announcements
to buy only cage-free eggs.
Starbucks has made a
pledge, Burger King.
We just announced Kellogg's and
General Mills, Hilton Hotels,
huge food service companies
like Compass Group, and Aramark,
and Sodexo.
A big corporate revolution
is happening on this front.
And if you shop at
Whole Foods, you'll
see that Whole Foods is
providing more information
to consumers about
animal products
than any other company.
It's using a program called
the Global Animal Partnership.
You can see it here.
And they certify
products on 1 to 5+.
So if you look for chicken or
turkey, you can get Level 1,
Step 1, Step 3, Step 5
product if they've got it in.
And each of these levels
conforms to a strict set
of animal welfare standards.
So 1 is a more humane standard,
but it goes higher levels
as the numbers go higher.
So 5 is the most humane.
And this is giving
consumers more information.
We're hoping that
the other big food
retailers adopt this system.
It's not owned by Whole Foods.
Whole Foods had a
role in developing it.
But this is a potential
revolution in the market.
And of course, the other
revolution-- by the way,
Whole Foods, which is now
a $16 billion company,
now is the principal GAP selling
company-- products from GAP.
And already it's had an effect.
I mean, each year
290 million animals,
2,600 farms-- so you see
the power of corporations.
When they make a
decision, it really
ripples out and
has a big effect.
And in the broader
sense, though, there's
no way we can continue
to eat as much meat
as we're doing in our society.
We're eating too much.
We have basically the
highest per capita meat
consumption in the world,
and it's not sustainable.
And Bill Gates, on
his Facebook page,
was talking about this issue.
And he said by 2030, the world
will need millions of tons
more meat than it does today.
But meeting that demand
with animal products
isn't sustainable.
The meat market is
ripe for reinvention.
Because when you think
about, Frances Moore Lappe
wrote about this 40 years ago
in "Diet for a Small Planet."
Animals are protein
factories in reverse.
We take a lot of
plant matter, put it
into the bodies of animals,
and they convert it
into a small amount
of animal protein.
And the ratios are 10 or
12 or 13 pounds of grain
to produce one pound of
beef, seven pounds of grain
pork, three or four pounds
to produce one pound of chicken.
There's tremendous
waste and loss.
I mean, the animals
are emitting heat.
They're keeping
their organs going.
They're defecating.
There's all this energy loss.
If we ate more plants directly,
we would much more efficiently
use the food stuffs
in the world.
And of course, then
there's the water issue.
I mean, you could
float a battleship
on what a cow needs in terms
of his or her water needs.
Because again,
they're emitting heat.
The body has needs for water.
And they're urinating a
lot of it out as well.
So west of the 20-inch rain
line in the United States,
irrigation is a big thing.
And I don't need to tell you
in California what you're going
through on the water issue.
There are companies that are now
developing plant-based proteins
that replicate the taste
and texture of meat,
and provide equal or,
typically, superior nutritional
content-- as much
or more protein,
more in the way of nutrients,
without the fat, cholesterol,
hormones, other
chemicals that are now
into the systems
of these animals.
This is one company
called Beyond Meat.
You can see its logo on
the upper right-hand side.
The future of meat is
meatless-- just as tasty.
So why shouldn't-- I
mean, just like fur--
if you can replicate the
look of fur, the style of it,
the quality, why do you
need to kill the animals?
If you can develop plant-based
proteins that duplicate it,
with much less in the way of
resource use, and no animal
cruelty, it seems to be a
very logical argument for us.
And the company that Josh
started, in its latest round,
raised $90 million.
I think they had $150 million
in offers for their Series C
investment round--
fastest-growing food company
in the world, ever.
The biggest companies--
Walmart, Sodexo, Compass Group--
all want this product,
because not only is it
better in terms of nutrition
and equivalent in taste,
it's cheaper.
It makes sense.
I mean, if you're putting
all that energy into animals
who inefficiently convert
it to the product,
when you could just
use the plants,
the energetics are
obviously in favor
of the more efficient use.
And that should be
reflected in cost.
That's what's going on.
So that's why there's a
real revolution that's
going on right now.
And these are some of
our different campaigns--
stopping extreme confinement,
ending puppy mills,
dealing with horse slaughter,
protecting marine mammals,
having anti-cruelty laws
throughout the world,
ending the year of cosmetic
and toxicity testing
on animals, and much more.
So we'd love for you
guys to get involved.
We're at HumaneSociety.org.
We'd love for you
to become a member.
We'd love for you to sign
up as a monthly donor.
But most important, we
want you to get involved,
because it's consumer
activism that's
driving the humane economy.
So thanks for listening
to my discourse.
And appreciate your
being here today.
Happy to take any questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So that the slide
that you showed with ivory
had some figurines,
and that sort of thing.
I'm wondering what uses of
ivory there are in the US
that it's a big import for us.
WAYNE PACELLE:
Yeah, the ivory is
used for a variety of purposes.
It used to be widely
used with pianos
and other musical instruments.
But Steinway, and now
Yamaha, don't use ivory.
And it's mainly in
trinkets-- little carved,
decorative items.
And China is the
number one consumer.
And the US is the
second largest consumer.
We're supporting a ballot
initiative, which is actually
being financed principally
by Paul Allen, the co-founder
of Microsoft this November
in Washington State,
to ban any sale of
ivory as well as
the parts of nine other
endangered animals.
We have a bill in California
to ban the ivory trade here.
It's already
through one chamber.
It's looking very positive.
And we're working with US
Fish and Wildlife Service
on a national rule on the issue.
But there is kickback
from folks who
are in the antiques
business, music industry,
as well as the NRA, because
they want to shoot elephants,
or they want their members
to be able to shoot
elephants and import
the ivory into the US.
So if you go to our website, and
then you go to our state page,
you can find information on
the bill here in California.
You can write to your
lawmakers, and get this done.
And then we want Governor
Brown to sign this bill later
in the year-- very important.
California is the biggest
market with New York.
And we did pass a bill
last year in New York
to stop the trade
in ivory there.
AUDIENCE: So it's
mainly trinkets?
WAYNE PACELLE: Trinkets, yup.
So think of these
beautiful, huge elephants
being killed as trinkets.
There's something
ironic about that.
AUDIENCE: Why is the reason, or
maybe the reason I'm not aware
of it, lobbying for controlling
the breeding of dogs,
like breeders registry,
breeder control, breeding only
on demand?
There's many aspects of it.
And also health issues
from inner breeding
and unhealthy dogs, and
so on, and so forth,
that creates a lot of these
rescue animals eventually, too.
WAYNE PACELLE: Yeah, you
think economically there
should be a cost born by
people who are breeding,
because they are contributing
to a population problem
that the rest of
society is dealing with.
It's the reason you have
Santa Clara County Animal Care
and Control spending
millions of dollars,
why you have private
humane organizations caring
for all these animals.
If you add up the cost, it's
a couple of billion dollars
a year in our society.
But right now, we treat
everyone with, essentially,
no tax on this behavior.
There have been attempts
to have a fee for breeding.
But it's been resisted.
There's still, in our
country, this great tension
we have between
liberty and justice.
And I think that there are
folks who say, I'm responsible.
I'm doing it right.
I shouldn't be penalized.
And that has been
a difficult thing
to overcome in
state legislatures.
I think what we're
trying to do is normalize
the discussion about spaying and
neutering, and about adoption.
And we're trying to attack,
with our Shelter Pet Project
advertising campaign, which
is a national advertising
campaign, the stigma associated
with animal shelter animals--
that they're not
problem animals.
It's usually a
human problem that
resulted in the animal
being relinquished.
Someone got divorced.
They moved.
They went to an apartment
that wouldn't allow animals.
It's not the animal's fault.
The animal's not defective.
So there's this notion somehow
that, while the breeder's
animals are better, get one
of these puppy mill dogs,
as we do all the time,
because we raid them.
They're sick.
They're inbred.
There are all sorts of problems.
The mixed breed animals are
actually much healthier,
because they have a much
richer genetic diversity.
And it means they've got
fewer of these chronic
and hereditary
problems that plague
certain breeds like bulldogs.
They have this pushed-in face.
They can't breathe very well.
Dachshunds have
this elongated back.
And they have back trouble.
German shepherds
have hip problems.
Almost all the breeds have
a laundry list of problems.
So when you get more diversity,
and you mix the breeds,
they have many fewer
health problems.
Some of the large breed dogs
that can't live past seven
or eight years-- I mean,
these are our creations
of selective breeding.
And there are lots
of physical problems
that are borne by the
consumer in terms of higher
veterinary cost, as well
as the emotional pain
of having to see your animal
suffering or dying prematurely.
AUDIENCE: It more has
to do with marketing.
I found out that you're
right, but a lot of people
still want a purebred.
So what I found out is
that people are not aware
that you can get a
purebred in rescue.
And there's many,
many purebred rescues.
And they have this notion
that all dogs in rescue
are mixed dogs, it's mainly
pit bulls, and so on.
And they never go to
even-- they don't know.
They just don't know.
They go and pay $2,000
for a purebred dog,
and they don't know they could
have got one from a rescue.
WAYNE PACELLE: That's one of
the many reasons why I want you
to read my new book coming out.
Because petfinder.com is part
of this humane revolution.
Petfinder.com loads
pictures and information
about available dogs and
cats, homeless dogs and cats.
You can get any
kind of dog that you
want by searching the website.
If you go to a physical
brick and mortar shelter,
you may not find
the animal you want,
even though one third of them
are purebreds in shelters.
But now you can find one.
President Obama wanted
a Portuguese water dog.
He could've gone on petfinder
and found a Portuguese water
dog.
You don't need to
go to a breeder.
You can get any kind of dog that
you want through this channel.
So you're right.
AUDIENCE: Speaking
of pit bulls, I'm
wondering if you could
speak to any work that's
being done about changing their
very unfortunate and undeserved
reputation in shelters?
WAYNE PACELLE:
Yeah, well, pitbulls
are really not even a breed.
We call them pit bull-type dogs.
There are different kinds of
dogs-- American Staffordshire
terrier and others.
And they definitely have
been the victims of stigma.
If you look back
historically in our culture,
there were different
dogs who were
viewed as the most menacing
and aggressive over time.
In the post-slavery
era, bloodhounds
were viewed as the
most vicious dogs.
You can see pictures of
them, and their depictions
in popular culture and in art.
They were the vicious ones.
They were chasing slaves,
and trying to get them back.
When I was a kid, it
was Doberman Pinschers.
There was also, before that,
it was German shepherds.
There was a real craze with
Rottweilers for awhile.
So pit bulls have
been kind of dominant
as the badass dog for
the last 20 or 25 years.
And some of it-- I went
to a fascinating lecture
from a guy who works with
the Canine Research Center.
And you can see these
popular media caricatures
of the dogs that
have really driven
this phony impression of them.
And I don't know if any of you
remember the "Little Rascals,"
but Petey, the dog, was
a pit bull-type dog.
They were the great
American dog at one point.
There is a circumstance
where some people, who
are not well-behaved
themselves, get these dogs.
And then they color the
behavior of the dogs.
And it's because of
that sort of morphing
of the dog based
on human behavior
that this reputation develops.
They are the most commonly
used dogs in fighting rings.
But they were specifically
bred and trained
not to attack the
people, because they're
in with their handlers
when they're fighting.
And they were bred and
trained to attack other dogs,
but not to attack people.
So there are lots of
convoluted parts of this.
The chairman of our board
is a big pit bull enthusiast
and he sleeps with three
in his bed every night.
And we have a dogs in the office
policy at the Humane Society.
I know you do at Google, as
well, which is fantastic.
We wrote a book about
there's dogs in the office,
and invoked Google's own policy.
And the dogs are
so well behaved.
And it's just a question
of properly raising them.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
ask you specifically
about an issue happening right
now around the New York Blood
Center.
I know you wrote a letter
to the New York Blood Center
a few months ago.
And for those of
you who don't know,
maybe you can speak to it
more eloquently than I.
But there was a chimpanzee
colony in Liberia
that's been used for
biomedical research
by the New York Blood
Center for decades.
And New York Blood Center has
recently essentially abandoned
them, and ceased all
funding for their care.
So the specific
question I have is,
what can people like
myself do to encourage
non-profit organizations
or corporations that
have $100s of millions in
funding to do the moral thing,
and meet their commitments?
WAYNE PACELLE: Well, you
articulated that very well.
Thank you for doing that.
Thank you for following it.
I mean, this is a case of
someone creating a problem,
and passing the cost
on to someone else.
So after the New
York Blood Center,
which is a large charity-- a
public health-oriented charity
that obviously does
blood-oriented work,
important work-- they had
used chimps in research,
stopped using them, had this
colony of them in Liberia,
was supporting them to
maintain their health
and well being, as they had
pledged to do a number of years
ago.
Again, if you use
a chimpanzee-- this
is what happens in film
as well, or commercials.
Here you see these cute infant
or juvenile chimpanzees.
When they get to be
seven or eight years old,
they become too
powerful to maintain.
They can't be used on set.
They live for 60 years,
so they dump them
onto us and other animal welfare
groups and chimp protection
groups.
We have to care for
them another 50 years.
We're talking about it
costs, on average, $17,000
to care for a chimp every year.
Look at that times 50 years.
It's approaching
$1 million dollars.
So where does
responsibility come in?
That kind of goes
to your question.
People create the problem, then
they dump it on the rest of us?
We need a fuller accounting of
what's going on in our society.
We need a fuller accounting
of factory farming.
I mean, we think
of this cheap meat,
where we have all
these public health
costs that are transferred
to society in terms
of heart disease and obesity.
We have public health risks in
terms of antibiotic resistant
bacteria, because we're dosing
these animals with antibiotics.
They're dumping their manure
in our streams and our lakes,
and they're poisoning
fish, and diminishing
the recreational qualities of
these water areas-- on and on.
So the New York Blood
Center as a charity
just completely
dropped the ball.
And we're picking up the slack.
But we shouldn't have to.
I'd say keep tabs
on our website.
We're urging people to
write to the Blood Center,
hold them accountable.
And I can assure you
that we're not going
to let them get away with it.
We're going to
stick with the plan.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about how you guys are working
with veterinarians, specifically
for live animal veterinarians,
and also food animal vets.
WAYNE PACELLE: Well,
we have a division
called the Humane Society
Veterinary Medical Association.
So we have about 7,000 vets,
or about 70,000 to 80,000 vets
in the US.
Most of them are
small animal vets,
but there are
categories of them.
There are farm animal vets,
lab animal vets, equine vets.
And we're trying to get
vets in a bigger leadership
position in animal protection.
Most vets historically worked
for the industries that
were causing harm to animals.
And they then internalized,
and then externalized
their value system.
And they were part
of the problem.
Now, with women now dominating
veterinary school slots--
it used to be 90/10 male
to female in vet schools.
Now it's 90/10 females.
And with small animal
vets caring for pets,
not associated with
these industries,
there's a big revolution
happening in the vet field.
We want to encourage it.
And that's why we've got the
Humane Society Veterinary
Medical Association working.
So thank you all very much.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks, everyone, for taking
time from your work day.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]